que piden los manifestantes en Perú
el cierre del legislativo el mismo que
los inconformes culpan de la
inestabilidad que vive el país
suramericano seis presidentes han caído
en medio de pulsos con el congreso
dominado por la derecha en al menos
cinco años por la salida de Pedro
castillo y la
derecha más que agradarse y entrar en un
capítulo en otro grado la liberación de
castillos es otra de las exigencias el
ex mandatario se encuentra en prisión
preventiva mientras es procesado por
presunta rebelión y conspiración al
intentar la disolución del parlamento
nosotros vamos a continuar hasta que
nuestro presidente se ha puesto en
libertad Otro aspecto clave es la
conformación de una asamblea
Constituyente su objetivo sería reformar
la Constitución específicamente lo
referido a la vacancia presidencial por
incapacidad moral un lineamiento creado
para sacar del poder a un mandatario por
inconvenientes de salud pero que el
congreso no ha dudado en utilizar como
arma contra varios presidentes Alberto
fujimori y Martín vizcarra han sido
blancos de esta jugada política también
piden la renuncia del actual presidente
Dina boluarte designada por el hemiciclo
peruano para sustituir a Pedro Castillo
era una antigua partidaria del
expresidente y hoy considerada traidora
Por quienes piden un cambio nosotros
estamos pidiendo no de que la renuncia
inmediata de la señora dinamburbarte
porque es una señora que ha usurpado con
no ha cumplido con todo el procedimiento
legal para asumir ese cargo la actual
mandataria intentó calmar las
manifestaciones pidiendo al congreso que
adelante las elecciones otro de los
reclamos que Hasta no ver materializado
los seguidores afirmaron que
continuarían en las calles eran cometido
una atentado magia contra el presidente
Pedro Castillo han atentado contra la
voluntad popular donde tenemos que
defender la democracia aquí y darle una
lección a todos estos golpistas los
enfrentamientos entre las fuerzas del
orden y los manifestantes impulsaron al
nuevo gobierno a declarar el estado de
emergencia nacional durante 30 días